تحت الوصايه يفتح النار مجددا على منى زكي
انتقادات ومطالبات بعدم عرض المسلسل
واتهامها بالاساءه للمحجبات
منى زكي شخصيه الاسبوع في صباح العربيه
العام الماضي قبل فيلم اصحاب ولا عزب حمله
انتقادات شرسه باعتباره يهدف لهدم قيم
المجتمع وقتها نالت النجمه منى زكي النصيب
الاكبر من الهجوم والسبب مشهد صنف على انه
جريء ويسيء للمراه المصريه الحملات كانت
عنيفه حتى ضد زوجها الفنان احمد حلمي مع
صدور فيلمه واحد ثاني في مايو من العام
الماضي قيل وقتها انه يروج للرذيله ونشر
الفسق لكن اخرون فسروا لها الانتقادات
بغرض الانتقام منه لانه زوج منى زكي اكثر
تحت الوصايه في الواقع لا يناقش قصه
الحجاب او خلعه بحسب ما وردته التقارير
الفنيه انما يدور حول ام تطر لعمل بمهنه
الصيد بعد وفاه زوجها لتعيل طفليها وتواجه
صراعات مع المجتمع الذكوري الرافض لها
هي ليست المره الاولى التي تجسد فيها منى
زكي دور امراه محجبه سبق وان قدمت الدور
بشكل ايجابي
سهر الليالي ارتدت الحجاب وخلعته في مسلسل
لعبه نيوتن عندما
تعرض في تجربه زواجها الثاني وتعاطف مع
المشاهدون المثير للاهتمامه
في رمضان المقبل مثلا محجبه في مسلسل
العمده كريم صعيديه محجبه في عمله نادره
والحان نفسه بالنسبه للفنانه روجينا من
مصر سالنا الناس ما رايكم بالجدل القائم
حول منى زكي ومسلسلها الجديد
هي نفس الحجاب في المسلسل وفي البوستر بس
يعني مخليه شكلها وحش جدا
ويعني بتوري الناس ان الحجاب بيوحش البنت
بما ان هو عكس كده اساسا بيه يعني هو
بيحلل البنت الحجاب ستره طول ما الحجاب
ستره والواحده الستره نفسها الستره حلوه
بشعرهم بيبقوا طالعين واو وشكلهم جميل
وفوضعه يعني الناس بتقول الله طب نعمل
شعرنا كده طب نعمل ميك اب ده طيب اشمعنا
بالحجاب ما دام انت طالعه في الشكل ده مش
كل الشعب المصري مكتئب عشان لابس حاجات
خالص
بتجسد شخصيه مش معنى كده اللي منى زكي
طالعه تقاره الناس في حته الحجاب او او
[موسيقى]
من القاهره ينضم لنا نقد الفني رامي متولي
سيد رامي اهلا بك اولا بالجدل حول بوستال
تحت الوصايه لمنى زكي البعض اعتبره اساءل
المراه المصريه واساءه للحجاب كيف ترى ذلك
هذا الجدل
اهلا بحضرتك الفكره ان دي وجهه نظر ضيقه
جدا للرؤيه للموضوع البوستر ده
عن شخصيتها في العمل الفني
في المسلسل طالعه امراه
بتقول
اولاد ما عندهاش مصدر فاكيد مش هيكون فيه
ظروف ضاغطه بتمنعها ان هي تعمل ده عندها
اولويات اخرى في طبيعه الشخصيه الدراغيه
وبالتالي دي ظهرت على على البوستر او على
المواد الدعائيه الخاصه
بالمسلسل
لكن المشكله ان البعض في السوشيال ميديا
تلقى هذه هذه الدعايه بشكل موجهها بشكل
اخر بحيث انها تروح كانها قضيه ضد الحجاب
فده مش صحيح بدليل ان ان الحجاب في الشارع
المصري
موجود في كل التطبيقات جدا
ومستويات مختلفه بتتعامل معك لماذا دائما
الممثل هو من يدفع الثمن يعني لماذا لا
يتم توجيه النقد والاتهامات للكاتب
والمخرج هو بالنهايه ممثل يقوم بالدور
الملقى على عاتقه
منى زكي ما السبب
هو اعتقد ان السبب الحقيقي والفعلي هو
حاله عامه على السوشيال ميديا في حاله
نقول الهجوم على الفن والفنانين بشكل
رئيسي في نظره نقدر نقول ان هي نظره ممكن
تكون قاسيه جدا ناحيه الفنانين والتعامل
مش مع منى زكي بس بالعكس التعامل ده
احيانا قد ينال
حضرتك سمعاني كده على الاحسن ان شاء الله
دائما في مشكله في الهجوم على الفنانين
عموما مش على منى زكي لكن بيبقى في مشكله
عامه على السوشيال ميديا اعتقد ان التواجد
خلف الشاشه بيدي نوع من انواع الجراءه في
الهجوم على
الفنانين البعض بيحس ان هي مساحه امنه
يعني وبعدين استاذ رامي يعني في كذا مره
بيصير بوستر لعائله فيلم او لمسلسل عمل ما
بتثير عليه ضجه مش دعايه ببلاش كمان
اه هي طبعا بتعتبر نوع من انواع الدعايه
سواء سلبيه او ايجابيه بتصب في مصلحه
العامه عمل بشكل او باخر لكن ما نقدرش
ننكر ان ممكن يكون الدعايه دي لها تاثيرها
سلبي على
على الفنان نفسه يعني اكيد اي فنان هو
عنده مشاعر بتتاثر بالهجوم ده وقد تؤدي
الى يعني شعوره سلبا او احباطه او كون ان
العمل حتى لم لم يعرف بعد بيتعرض لهذا
الهجوم وهذه وهذا من بين الانتقالات قبل
ما يتعرض يعني بنسبه كبيره ممكن يكون
العمل جيد يعني
بنفترض دائما للعمل ممكن يكون جيد او على
الاقل في عنصر او عنصرين ممكن يكون سلبي
شويه لكن في في المجمل العمل مقبول ومنى
زكي تحديدا لو بنتكلم عنها هي سوبر ستار
فالفكره هنا بشكل او باخر ان الهجوم ده قد
يؤثر سلبا على
الفنانين وعلى العمل يعني
بنشكرك جزيل الشكر ناقد الفني رامي متولي